[Musique]
Morbius est apparu pour la première fois en tant qu'antagoniste
dans L'incroyable homme-araignée en 1971 et a
finalement évolué pour devenir davantage un
anti-héros si vous voulez
le faire maintenant
pendant des années avant que cette merveille ne soit
en fait interdite d'utiliser des personnages
considérés comme plus importants.  le côté surnaturel
donc c'était vraiment un gros problème quand Morbius a
finalement fait ses débuts, il y a quelque chose
en moi
qui veut chasser
[la musique]
et consommer du sang,
il faisait partie d'un tournant beaucoup plus sombre au sein de
Marvel One que heureusement les fans ont pleinement
adopté après tout tout le monde  j'adore les bonnes
histoires de monstres, il y
a quelque chose dans le personnage
qui a stimulé l'imagination des gens,
il peut vraiment t'attraper,
ce qui m'a certainement fait
te voir au cinéma,
tu